at this hour the battle for control of
the senate is
also undecided our chief congressional
correspondent nancy cordes is here with
us nancy good morning
so how's it looking well we've got a
very uncertain picture right now we
thought that we were heading towards a
very good shot at a democratic majority
in the senate
but right now that path is narrowing
take a look
here's just a reminder of how we started
the night republicans with a slim
majority
53-47 now let's take a look at where
things stand
take a look at the right side of your
screen that's the republican side of the
senate chamber a 3d
view of it you see a couple of spots of
blue there arizona
looking like a likely pickup for
democrats colorado
a pickup for democrats for sure and now
take a look at
those few white desks on that right-hand
side there are still
four seats on the right-hand side that
have not been decided and democrats need
to
win at least two or three of them to
take control of the senate
so we'll take a look at those one by one
first of all there's north carolina
also hasn't been called at the
presidential level about 94 percent of
the vote in there
and you've got tom tillis the the uh
incumbent with a two-point
lead so we can't call that's right
cunningham had a pretty good lead yeah
he did and this is just an example of
democrats underperforming
all across the country looking a lot
worse than the polls
had showed them we can't say for sure
which way this race is going to go
there's some very important data that's
still not in but that's a tough race
that is
far from a shoe-in for democrats so then
let's go to maine where susan collins
despite the polling has a lead at this
hour
over sarah gideon now only about 66
percent of the vote has been counted
there
they are just slow and there is another
problem in maine which is that they
use something called ranked choice
voting if no one gets to 50
and if you take a look here susan
collins is at 49.5 percent right now
if nobody gets above 50 they ship all
the ballots to augusta
and they look at what people's second
choice was
for senate so there is actually a
wonderfully civilized way to do it
it pushes people toward the center
instead of pushing them to the polls
it keeps an independent from being a
spoiler because they get four percent of
the vote
makes it very complicated on election
day though true it sure does and there
is an independent candidate who's
getting about 4.5 percent of the vote
she has told people
hey if i don't win put sarah gideon the
challenger is your second choice
so a lot still up in the air and then
let's take a look at the two races in
georgia
just like the presidential level we
can't make a call here yet david perdue
with a lead
over john ossoff with about 91 percent
of the vote in and then
this other georgia race is definitely
going to be going to a runoff
in january so the question now is
whether you got two races in georgia
going to a runoff
or one but either way it looks like i'm
headed to buckhead for the holidays you
have more work to do
there was a phrase that you used a
couple times there despite the polls and
i think we're going to be using that a
lot of the days
oh and i just want to point out
something to you really quickly look
over here on the democratic side of the
leisure michigan
is now a toss-up for the incumbent gary
peters if democrats can't hold on to
that seat
their path to the majority closes almost
again despite the polls we're going to
be having a bigger conversation about
that in the days ahead because this
thing is tight at the senate level and
also the presidential
level tighter than a lot of people
thought all right nancy cordes thank you
very much